Так.
Отже, рухаємося вперед — є біти
і qubit-и стануть фундаментальною обчислювальною основою,
за допомогою якої ми зможемо розв'язувати
складні проблеми у світі.
Тож спробуймо зрозуміти різницю між ними
і де криється сила qubit-ів.
Якщо подивитися на ліву частину —
це спосіб опису, і ми будемо використовувати ці діаграми
впродовж усієї презентації, щоб
показати потужність. Ми бачимо коло
і дві точки: коли точка на північному полюсі —
це нуль, коли на південному полюсі — одиниця.
Це класичний біт із двома станами. А qubit —
це одиниця інформації у квантовому світі.
І тут нам допомагає ця картинка:
вся сфера — це нуль і одиниця.
І ми можемо мати їх у цьому стані суперпозиції.
У нас є особливий прийом, доступний нам:
ми можемо не лише розміщувати стани на цій сфері,
а й уявімо, що кожен із них —
це маленький місяць,
що знаходиться на сфері, і ми можемо обертати цей місяць.
Тож ось ти бачиш,
що нижня сфера трохи повернута,
ось чому видно трохи блакитного
і рожевого — і ми могли б повернути її повністю.
Ось поворот на сто вісімдесят градусів.
Отже, ми маємо це поняття фази, яке квантова механіка нам дає.
Квантові технології дають нам три надздібності,
що виявляються у qubit-ах.
Це надздібності суперпозиції,
інтерференції
та заплутаності. Розгляньмо їх. Принцип суперпозиції насправді
доволі просто зрозуміти.
Отже, зірка в лівій частині:
ми маємо або нуль (північний полюс), або одиницю (південний полюс).
І якщо ми додамо ці два стани,
то отримаємо qubit у суперпозиції, що має одночасно
нуль і одиницю — і на північ,
і на південь. Права діаграма — та сама,
але зараз ми зробимо маленький трюк:
застосуємо gate — квантовий gate.
Те, що ми зробили тут — пам'ятаєш —
ми можемо змінювати, тобто
обертати ці маленькі місяці, правда?
Отже, ми повернули його на сто
вісімдесят градусів і тепер маємо одиницю.
Тож коли ми додаємо нуль плюс одиниця, отримуємо
стан суперпозиції,
але зверни увагу — він інший.
У тому, що ліворуч, ми маємо
той самий нуль і одиницю, але тепер із поверненим станом
для одиниці. І це буде дуже потужно
для використання другої справді цікавої речі —
принципу інтерференції.
І це операція, якої немає у класичному
світі бітів. Отже, у цьому прикладі ми маємо
нуль і одиницю ліворуч плюс
новий стан, який ми створили, —
теж нуль і одиниця,
але з цим поверненим місяцем. Коли ми це робимо,
ми отримуємо змогу інтерферувати ці два стани,
і зверни увагу на щось справді цікаве:
ми анулювали стан одиниці
і отримали стан нуля.
Ми зробили це завдяки інтерференції станів.
Тож наступне питання, яке постає перед нами прямо зараз, —
скільки станів ми можемо створити?
І чудова річ у квантових обчисленнях — ми можемо створити експоненціальну
кількість станів. Розглянемо систему, що має
п'ять qubit-ів. У цьому випадку ми зображуємо ці qubit-и
як незалежні qubit-и — бачиш їх ліворуч:
нулі та одиниці, і вони перемножуються. Ми маємо п'ять
з них, тож кількість станів, які ми можемо створити у
квантовому комп'ютері, зображеному на сфері праворуч, —
це два в степені
кількості qubit-ів, які ми маємо. У цьому випадку нас п'ять,
тож два в п'ятому степені — це тридцять два стани.
Отже, ми бачимо тридцять два таких маленьких місяці.
Зверни увагу, що в цьому випадку ми не врахували
жодної фази — всі вони рожеві. Потужний аспект
використання цієї властивості, що називається заплутаністю у квантовому світі,
полягає в тому, що ми можемо створювати стани,
як той, що зображений праворуч, —
де ми маємо ці комбінації рожевого
і синього, де цей стан не можна описати
як незалежний добуток
цих п'яти qubit-ів. У цьому випадку,
оскільки ми маємо тридцять два стани,
це говорить нам про щось дуже глибоке.